now still with no plans for biden or
harris to ever visit the southern border
and see
firsthand the crisis they themselves
created gop senators they are exposing
exactly how bad these conditions have
deteriorated on our border
or 18 of them that have been down there
one of them lindsey graham will join us
tonight
he's calling for biden to apologize to
border patrol agents
who tried to warn the biden transition
team that a surge was coming
especially with the scrapping of the
highly successful remaining mexico
policy
and stopping building the wall what
we're seeing on the border is a
full-fledged catastrophe
the photos that they don't want you to
see that we've been able to get
tell you the whole story overcrowded
facilities
strained resources no transparency no
accountability
no media gag orders you name it and no
solutions
from anybody on team biden the
administration instead is more focused
on reckless spending
more tax hikes more blue state bailouts
more attacks on your second amendment
oh that joe biden might use an executive
fee out on that too
as senator graham is also defending the
use of for example his own
ar-15 saying he owns one for
self-defense
good for him so do i here to react to
all of it south carolina senator lindsey
graham except
i have the modified new york state legal
model
uh which basically takes cosmetics and
makes people think it's something that
it's not
because they don't know anything about
guns to begin with but i have to follow
the law
because you and i both know they'd love
to put me in jail forever
uh let's go to the border first this is
why i don't live in new york okay
don't well you're lucky i'm stupid i
admit it uh
now but here's my question you're down
at the border
did they really tell you senators well
first of all they told border patrol
agents they could no longer do
interviews right alongs
then they're not allowing any pictures
we still haven't seen the inside of one
of those cargo shipping
containers that they're putting kids in
you
tell us what you saw and then they
wanted to delete your phones
sure well i saw a giant cover up i can
understand why the biden administration
would not want the american people to
know what's going on i saw massim
massive system failure i told you about
this during the transition do you
remember
during the holidays i told you this
would be the biggest issue
for the country the reason i told you
that is the border patrol agents were
that i know were telling me
they're going back to the old policy
they're going to do away with remaining
mexico
and they're changing the unaccompanied
minor uh
policy of trump so what what did i see i
saw 200 plus
women and small children being processed
in front of me
that were going to be released into the
united states within eight hours
i saw children with numbers on their
risk and here's what that means
they have family member members in the
united states sean
they send money back to central america
they hire a human smuggler human
trafficker
to get them to the border once we catch
them
your tax dollars are used to reunite the
family
this is not catch and release this is
catch and reunite
they call the family member the number
on the child's wrist
and the american taxpayer pays to
reunite the family who's here illegally
it will send the wrong signal we'll have
half of central america in the united
states
in a year if we don't change these
policies and the conditions in which
these kids
live in were terrible all right i'm
looking at these videos so let's keep up
these videos i think those in particular
were from senator cruz
and ron johnson was right too and that
is we had already solved this problem
this problem was fixed
yeah and of course then get in the way
shut off the camera
don't take pictures delete your phone
okay and then the gag order you can
enter this
now i'm going to tell you something
senator we know a high percentage of
people entering this
country illegally have coveted a lot of
them aren't even being tested
look at the conditions these are abusive
conditions for children
they're telling us why they're coming
because
uncle joe said come and seek asylum here
right
now if we want to reverse this for the
sake of the people
inside these overcrowded cages that joe
is building for them
um don't we have to firmly say you're
not getting in
and you got to go home yeah yeah
yeah send them back or you they're going
to keep coming i've never seen so many
incentives
for illegal immigration as i see today
if you're 16 and younger
we're going to make sure you never leave
the country if you have a family member
here illegally we're going to pay to
reunite
the family illegally that incentivizes
more illegal immigration
nobody stays in mexico anymore you claim
asylum in the united states
within about two weeks you're released
into the united states
without a court date uh by the summer
we're going to have 150 000 plus a month
if they don't change policy nothing's
going to change it's only going to get
worse
and i can just not tell you how hard it
is stress enough
the border patrol agents are being asked
to do something that's impossible
50 of the force is now processing
illegal immigrants
they're not following drug smugglers and
traffickers and terrorists trying to get
into their country they're overwhelmed
and if we don't change policy the worst
is by far yet to come
it is really heartbreaking sean sarah
sarah is doing a great job she's doing a
great job for your show but i would
i would encourage you to go if you see
what i saw
it would break your heart you'd be mad
as hell mad as hell
seeing what i see our cameras were there
i've been down on the board of senators
you know 14 times from the rio grande of
san diego
let me go let me go to this other issue
here and that is now we have joe biden
wanting to bypass
this whole other branch co-equal branch
of government again and
you know with a signature institute new
gun policies
my question is republican party
may have to all 50 of you to stop
the end of the legislative filibuster
because we know joe biden now wants to
change it
we know that joe manchin he's already
buckled i just want to make it harder so
we got the new talking point
will republicans then if that's what
they're going to do
if they unite all 50 of them they don't
have to show up in the senate chamber
and they don't get a quorum that's not a
situation as i understand it
where kamala harris can break a tie am i
wrong or am i right
and would republicans unite on that
issue to prevent
the end of the legislative filibuster
i'm confident that if they tried to
change the filibuster to pass the most
liberal agenda in the history of the
country
republicans would use every tool to stop
it including not giving their quorum
as to ar-15 ownership i own one i'm a
responsible gun owner
if you really believe that banning
ar-15s
are the answer to the problem bring up
the assault weapons ban
senator schumer and let's vote on it you
won't get 50 votes must let
60. so bring this radical gun agenda the
floor unless vote
i'm not afraid to vote why don't you
bring it up to the floor for vote
and see where the american people are at
when you come up to new york next time
i'll show you what they make you do in
new york to get a legal gun
you just can't believe it at one point
at one point i was
only allowed seven bullets in in the gun
i had to follow the law i follow the law
senator because
even you a great lawyer probably
couldn't get me out of jail in cuomo's
new york
and de blasio's new york thank you sir